beaucoup de mecs qui nous aime bien
quand même fait ce juste que c'est caché
ses dents tu vois c'est vraiment c'est
très très cash et après pour être en
couple après ma demande en tant que
femme trans accompli on va dire genre
vraiment qui est bien dans sa peau que
j'ai confiance en moi et c'est bon c'est
toujours autant compliqué
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
séquence totalement folle on y voit
slate le fils de 6 ans de kim et du
rappeur kanye west jouer avec l'ipad
familial quand soudain
le sac si oui il tombe sur une publicité
pour la sextape de sa maman et la
starlette de fondre en larmes au
téléphone avec cannes et
c'est pas très drôle mais quand même un
peu un abri
dans ces choses là oui chez désolé on va
pas pleurer pour elle c'est les limites
de l'argent facile en fait ça qu'il faut
dire à tous les jeunes aujourd'hui qui
sont tentés de vendre des contenus
dénudée a forcément des sextapes y en a
plein à tard elle me le faites pas parce
que les images elles restent et les gens
sont certes me trouve la mélasse l'armée
a tenté un gneiss excède un but d'ayew
c'était totalement commercial de débuter
sa mère qui reviennent et tout ça il dit
en seconde
et donc qui vient taper leurs étoiles
banon mais ça ne s'est pas l'élite
découvre pas oui mais bon service je
peux te le dire ils sont pétris d
intention et moi ce qui m'inquiète c'est
qu'en fait de guillaume dit oui mais là
tu t'adresses jeunes il faut pas je suis
désolé mais c'est hyper tentant de sa
sextape de devenir une carnation et à
poser
les aventures donc et non me tourne et
je dois y avait des photos de quoi et
qui circulait bien
mérité l'autre fort nous a demandé s'il
y avait des polars
c'est vrai qu'il y avait des photos
[Rires]
t'as quoi avec un mec connu bah oui ça
personnel
connu mais non mais attendez vous je
suis bon je vais
imprimer dans le magasin et tout mais on
a une chambre noire pour les autres
images non mais ça je sais pas ça mais
qu'ils en aient occupé donc l'enfant
chéri
[Rires]
ça c'est toi sur le balcon
c'est fou ça rigolait ah ouais mais
j'avais j'avais 19 ans ouais quand même
[Musique]
je lui ai caché que j'étais né dans le
corps d'un garçon
fait d'avoir entamé ma transition gelé
senti comme une libération si une
seconde naissance en fait je les ai
commencé à mes dix avant aujourd'hui je
me sens moi-même à 100% je suis fier
d'eux qui fut deux fois
alors eve eve lève toi
c'est vrai regardez
juste pour faire là-bas développe toi et
donc ça avec la vie merci d'être avec
nous alors f très sympathique mais eve
hier tu as été la star de ce programme
non mais c'est vrai c'était incroyable
alors tu étais donc avec quelques clics
alors tu es coiffeuse à coulon ouais
d'accord très bien m tu as tu as quel
âge à 23 23 ans alors toi donc est ce
que tu peux nous raconter quand a décidé
de devenir une femme bah en fait depuis
toujours un je suis cité tous et enfin
gelé senti en fait si je me sentais pas
bien tu te sentais pas bien grâce à six
mois avant j'avais 19 ans
nouvelle web tv dans sa main t elle
enfin et donc quoique sur à 19 ans tu
tenais avant je me sentais pas bien
ouais non mais mais mais même avant en
fête a pris la décision à 19 ans 9 enfin
voila j'ai commencé les démarches à
dinard et là tu es là tu es heureuse
lâche trop heureuse la chasse aux
draperies enfants bref si je suis bien
merci les du mal tu as du mal à trouver
l'amour
l'amour ouais on va dire après des
relations sexuelles ya aucun problème
bien sûr à ce que les mecs ils sont
enfin il ya beaucoup de mecs qui nous
aime bien quand même fait ce jusque
s'est caché c'est dans le futur c'est
c'est vraiment c'est très très cash et
après pour être en couple après ma
demande en tant que femme transfert
accompli on va dire genre vraiment qui
est qui est bien dans sa peau que j'ai
confiance en moi et c'est bon c'est
toujours autant compliqué parce qu'ils
assument par mature 13 tu as décidé de
participer à cette émission tu cherchais
vraiment l'amour pendant que franchement
mais parce que je me suis c'est un bon
concept est tout en fait je me suis pour
mac aux genres marché à fond dans la
cause et tout c'est pour ma cause en
fait ça serait cool de de montrer aux
gens qui en fait une femme trop ça peut
trouver l'amour un peu enfin c'est pas
genre quand on est des femmes normales
fin tu regardes n'est pas enfin je sais
pas si vous voyez ce que je veux dire
que si on réussit mal si les gens ils
voyaient que mais c'est important qu'ils
soient dans l'émission c'était voilà
c'est un mauvais garçon mais non
là c'est moi et les garçons en bas je
suis né dans le mauvais parent
[Musique]
je suis né j'ai des garçons maintenant
je suis une femme franche pour
son cocon jouer mes sentiments
genre sont fait que ya pas de sincérité
ça va
à ce moment là bas j'étais choqué en
fait je me suis dit mais [ __ ] en fait
je me suis la honte en fait c'est
pourquoi j'étais venu là pour faire
avancer les choses j'ai mal je me suis
je me suffis chat en fait au contraire
ça va les faire reculer ça va juste
confirmer tout ce que les gens pensent
que
je l'avais dit j'ai rencontré une femme
avant c'était un garçon situé au conseil
de faire croire
là mon coeur ndi la retrouver parce que
sur
chanson je dis tout et surtout qui
agissent et sincère oui je sais ça
indique le jugement qu'on a joué cartes
sur table maintenant j'ai envie d'aller
de l'avant avec elles n'ont eu que qu'on
ait voulu ensemble comprend tous
ensemble
[Musique]
j'en pense que cette rencontre c'est un
fake pourquoi vous connaissiez avec
taken avant y avait énormément de vidéos
comme par hasard ou les avait retiré
aujourd'hui lui aussi un jour où vous
voyez ensemble comme amis et même
peut-être ayant déjà été en couple avec
lui ayant déjà rompu nous allons nous et
ont retrouvé il ya deux versions soit
milan contre ma question aller simple
devant toutes ces preuves que vous avez
retiré aujourd'hui est-ce que vous
connaissiez y colle avant l'émission
alors je vais vous expliquer en fait par
rapport à ces photos fins et vidéos qui
ont été supprimés
il ya en fait les fidèles ont été faites
a pris le tournage en fait le tournage
ça a été le 3 février et en fait on a
dormi ensemble après alao au château
parce qu'en fait c'est bon tu sais si on
repart ensemble on dort ensemble après
mais là-bas au château on a confiance
était juste dormir on a juste dernis
rien ouais non et rien d'autre pas de
vrai nom nagy ce dernier
tour deuxième chose qui a heurté
certains c'est que michael sur les
réseaux sociaux sur tik tok notamment il
assume sa bisexualité n'a aucunement un
problème sauf que dans l'émission il est
quand même implicitement présenté comme
hétéro c'est ça on le voit sur des
vidéos et en se transformant avec dp rue
du maquillage et des tenues féminines
bas alors moi je vous ai gallia des
vidéos moi je faisais donc est-ce que
vous avez menti sur la nature de votre
relation au terrain perdu a expliqué en
fait moi et quelques enjeux les connu
emma je savais dirait dirait direct ans
à travers le petit taquet tout il était
dit que c'était un atout clé mais les
garçons et les femmes quand vous l'avez
connu donc avant donc l'art vous venez
vous griller
je pose les questions
de l'émission bien se connaître quand
même avant bah oui du coup ensuite en
fait quand j'avais vu sur tip top je
savais qu'il était bon et du coup par
mois ça ne posait pas de problème parce
que j'ai la joie et qu'il avait un côté
quand même masculin comme jeudi dans
l'émission voit il avait un côté
masculin et tout donc voilà ensuite on
est parti en tunisie et on a vécu une
semaine ensemble a récemment et c'est là
que j'ai vu qu'il était son côté il
avait un côté fait une entrée très voilà
quoi très présent et moi ça m'a un peu
dernièrement il était jaloux non il
avait un côté féminin enfin dans sa
manière d'être et caetera et ou qui me
dérangeait pas mais c'est juste que je
le voyais plus comment il était trop
femme
commence et delphine wespiser qui s'est
positionné plutôt en faveur des idées de
marine le pen elle a une forme de
bienveillance j'aimerais bien voilà une
maman des français quelqu'un qui
rassemble qui protège a contrario
bernamont qu'elle n'a jamais caché sa
proximité avec le président sortant
emmanuel macron c'est raquil prochain
président sera là pour vous écouter
j'espère que ce sera mais chez makro des
prises de positions qui sont désormais
comptabilisées comme des temps de parole
par l'arc sommes en pleine période
électorale jusqu'à dimanche delfini
bernanos exprimons donc plus en tant que
chroniqueur sur notre antenne alors
delphine et bernard montiel évincé de
tpm p comprenez vous cette décision
pour moi pour moi delphine et bernard
dans cette campagne politique sont deux
militants delphine à sa manière appelant
à voter marine le pen
passait dans ma phrase est ce que tu
peux me trouver une seule séquence où
j'ai de lui botter marine le pen oui oui
mais non non non j'ai fait un
argumentaire j'ai expliqué ce qui me
plaisait ce qui ne me plaisaient pas
dans ce qu'on a vécu point final est non
trouve moi la phrase j'en ai marre non
non y'avait géraldine qui m'a dit oui
mais alors voilà donc tu vote marine le
pen doit jeûner elsa il a dit
daddy de ma bouche ce n'est jamais sorti
je suis puni pourquoi ai je suis mis au
pot je suis mise au placard parce que
quoi j'étais trop courageuse il était
trop authentique j'ai dit ce que je
pensais pourquoi pas ce que j'ai fait
mon travail de chroniqueur on sait très
bien qu ici le but c'est de donner notre
avis sur la télé réalité sur des faits
de société et en ce moment sur deux la
politique du coup je devais faire toute
la semaine vous le savez on a parlé
ensemble donc concrètement je perds des
émissions donc je perds de l'argent et
donc c'est le prix ça ce que je perds
c'est le prix de la liberté j'avais pu
être n'importe quelle autre femme
d'ailleurs valérie pécresse si elle s'en
était mieux sorti je leur ai dit
pourquoi pas le côté maternel le côté
les femmes qui ont des couilles on aime
ça et on sait que les femmes qui ont et
comment
elles ont besoin d'amour des liens de
certains hommes et pourquoi est ce que
j'ai dit par exemple maman d'être maman
des français parce que ça m'a fait
penser par exemple à angela merkel ont
dit mouty vers nationaux ça m'a fait
penser nouveau dépôt la pop à londres
en israël aussi c'était c'était c'était
la maman denise réel c'est la même chose
c'est pour ça en fait que j'ai que j'ai
utilisé cette rhétorique c'est pas pour
autant que ça m'a fait basculer dans les
soutiens voilà fut juste une française
qui a été déçu et je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de personnes qui sont
derrière moi alors
je vous dis je suis condamné simplement
parce que je suis ami avec eux irene ce
sont des amis que j'adore que j'aime
profondément que je respecte maintenant
dans cette émission je n'ai jamais fait
du prosélytisme
j'ai jamais dit voter pour un tort voté
pour et parfois je le dis et
qu'en gagnant il a été toujours sur des
décisions il a dit aux employés
savaient qu'on peut avoir des amis ne
pas toujours être d'accord et souvent
j'étais contre des décisions dernier
avec guillaume genton parfois cela est
vrai que sa décision
est quelque chose d'intéressant si il ya
des influences ce zoo qui ne sont pas la
télé mais qui ont des millions de
personnes qui font des story en disant
je vote par exemple pour pour emmanuel
macron mais elles elles ne sont pas
censurés par exemple et on sait qu'au
cumul deux personnes à qui je pense
nabila et maeva ghanam elles ont elles
de 10 millions de personnes et les deux
ont dit ok on vote pour mac rompt donc
avec une story qui dure 24 heures donc
au niveau du temps de parole du des
comptes sont bons c'est beaucoup plus
que moi quand je dis on choisira pas
encore des règles
d'ailleurs puisqu'on les airs et syrien
pour leur jour d'hui on sait que les
réseaux sociaux les réseaux sociaux
c'est le nouveau média est en train de
surpasser la télé alors pourquoi est-ce
qu'on nous bride tellement à la télé et
on a souffert sur les réseaux sociaux
les gens c'est vrai qu'on s'engage en
politique c'est qu'on dise je vote le
pen parce qu'il chante l'opinion en tout
cas ça c'est vrai je suis lent et
lardons
n'y aurait pas eu tous ces
contrats il n'aurait pas été en danger
c'est dégueulasse bref un préfet m je
n'ai pas dit je vote le pen g j'ai parlé
de bienveillance en fait pour
contrebalancer le côté diabolique tout
le monde veut la diaboliser dos je la
fais je vois la gemmi bienveillance pour
qu'elle soit une candidate normal
comparer un candidat apparemment normal
bon même si le président sortant et du
coup il a plus de panache et tous
forcément j'aimerais juste que les gens
votent de manière égale et se disent ok
je peux faire ça ou je peux faire ça
parce que forcément si la pression et la
masse dit ok on diabolise ce côté ben
les gens il sait contraire c'est que
montre critique
pour le moment les chéris on est avec
cette affaire d'influenceurs résidant à
dubai doivent-ils s'exprimer sur la
présidentielle
c'est oui c'est nonce a fait couler
énormément d'encre
que vous voulez dire oui non mais les
gens qui critiquent nabil karoui les
aigris et des jaloux jusqu'à preuve du
contraire elle est française elle a
choisi de déménager sur à l'étranger
pour son métier mais aussi pour fuir
l'insécurité qu'elle ressentait en tant
que célébrité c'était ça oui
pardon mais qui sont ces gens et pour
déterminer les gens qui ont le droit de
7,2 s'exprime sur la campagne pré sence
à la pensée des hommes politiques
étrangers qui donnent leur avis landi
rien et concéda bilan la critique mais
arrêtez la vérité c'est que vous êtes
des aiguilles et des jaloux
non mais moi franchement j'adore maeva
ghanam j'adore nabila je les suis
j'adore regarder leurs sacs leur truc ce
qu'elles font machin mais parle moi de
culotte menstruel me parle pas du
président enfin je rejoins
en amont alors oui c'est ça ma tête j'ai
vu que le haut jusqu'à antonio qui est
vous de leurs mots j'ai hâte de vous
entendre franchement c'est du mépris de
la cité au nom de quoi vous dites ça le
paradis là franchement ma bilal a une
vraie vision de la société française
elle réfléchit à tout elle est appliquée
elle a des accents citoyens quoi qu'est
ce que la resega stahl dit toi arrête
arrête tout qu'on peut plus à défendre
et ne laissèrent pas non plus voilà il
exagère pas il exagère un peu quand même
d'ailleurs fait nabila quoi qu'il en
soit ok c'est une influence euse mais
c'est une citoyenne et elle a un cerveau
plus d'un confrère enfin nous alors il a
le recul il faut pas charrier ton mari
ben t'as pas besoin d'être marie curie
envie de voter t'intéresser ben ouais
mais qui est calme à l'eau mais en
revanche ce que je trouve la police est
le cousin de marie
je t'avais dit qui sont ces gens qui
donnent des leçons sur qui voter ils ont
pas la vie des frères etc moi je me dis
que si à vous donner son avis qu'est le
dessin mais en attendant elle n'a pas la
vie des français elle n'a pas la vie des
gens aller là-bas dubaï au soleil a fait
son business pour certains et touche 200
mille euros par mois alors complètement
déconnecté des français quand tu dis
allez partie de la france parce qu'elle
se sentait pas en sécurité
banks et d'ébriété ah bah oui mais
basile de revoter quand même président
pour qui voter pour célébrités voit la
france s'est fait cambrioler
ont voté pour la même personne
tous les influenceurs à dubaï pour se
faire virer sauf d'estibeaux m'a dit
benji et stéphanie durand et son chéri
pour tout à fait ces informations
certains influenceurs pourraient être
expulsés dans les prochains jours car il
entretiendrait des relations avec des
gens peu fréquentables et n'aurait
aucune société alors non dans le pays
alors les stars de télé-réalité bientôt
prié de quitter dubaï croyez vous à la
rumeur
oui alors hugo ils deviennent des stars
grâce à la télé française ils gagnent de
l'argent grâce aux français qui les
suivent sur les réseaux sociaux et
l'argent qu'ils gagnent des sommes
astronomiques on le sait tous ils vont à
dubaï pour ne pas payer d'impôts à leur
patrie et la france qu'on aime et qu'on
respecte moi s'il dubaï dégagent les
stars de télé réalité ça ne pose aucun
problème je pense qu'ils auraient bien
raison c'est pas vrai déjà il y en a qui
ont des sociétés domiciliées en france
ensuite ma j'enquête effectivement vous
pouvez être expulsés de dubaï si vous
commettez certaines fautes très graver
un crime un viol du trafic de
stupéfiants vous êtes automatiquement
expulsé si on rayonne voitures
qui sont ils sont très dur là dessus là
en l'occurrence ce sont des fausses
rumeurs basée sur le fait que ces
personnes génère énormément de jalousie
qu'elle gagne beaucoup d'argent et
qu'elles sont très critiquées notamment
par les français mais aucune de ces
personnalités n'est menacée d'expulsion
c'est basé aussi sur le fait on a
certaines qui songent à partir et qu'ils
ont plus ou moins annoncée nabila veut
partir notamment dans trois quatre ans
aux états unis mais ça n'a rien à voir
avec sa danse est une fausse rumeur
basée sur l'âge l on voit là j'y crois
pas une seule seconde c'est tout
bénéfice pour l'image de 12,2 de dubaï
world fashion c'est tout bénéfice est
réel vous rendez compte tout ce qu'ils
font comme comme buzz là dessus tous est
calé en quoi c'est un bénéfice pour
dubaï au dubai battant l'image qu'ils
donnent malgré tout à fait à temps avec
tous les suiveurs et tout ça pourquoi je
n'entends parler de dubaï
s'en fiche complète on savait oui mais
justement s'il s'en fichent ils vont pas
les expulser non plus comme dit
guillaume ils ont pas tuer père et mère
donc je n'y crois pas un seul instant
c'est de la pub oui pour le moment aucun
influenceurs aucune influence euzenat
reçu de lettre mettant fin aux visas cd
vise à prolonger entre 1 et 3 ans aucun
n'est visé juste il y en a 2 dont on
peut pas donner les noms parce qu'il ya
une procédure judiciaire contre eux qui
eux risquent l'expulsion mais ça n'a
rien à voir avec une volonté de dubaï de
virer les influenceurs absolument pas
beaucoup moins d'argent non mais en ce
moment on sait que les recettes où il y
avait 300 ou 400 mille euros par mois
par mois par mois on est plutôt de
diviser par 4
oui d'accord c'est comme les salades de
l'argent on fait quoi c'est ça fait
moins et puis c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
les nouveaux arrivés ken plus du tout
d'oseille du tout donc c'est plus sonné
le radeau donc ça va disparaître
[Musique]
on y voit un policier de la bac
appréhendé un homme dans un hall
d'immeuble et lui asséner des coups
il s'est filmé au blanc mesnil dans le
93 qui témoigne une fois de plus des
tensions entre les jeunes et la police
des fois vous êtes tellement énervée
la préfecture de police a immédiatement
saisi l'igpn pour établir les
circonstances dans lesquelles les fait
monter par ces images se sont produits
je les ai pas je ne fais pas ce qui
s'est passé qu'est ce qui s'est passé il
ya deux personnes qui ceux qui se
battent pour qu'on va suspendre ce
policier s'est peut-être fait agresser
il a le droit de riposter voilà ce que
je veux dire le contraire comme
d'habitude les deux versions dans le
rapport des plats m'assieds eux ils
expliquent donc ce sont des policiers de
la bac il explique donc il voulait
contrôler un jeune homme qui entrait
dans un hall d'immeuble ils rendent pour
le contrôler le jeune homme refuse
d'obtempérer donne des coups et à ce
moment là il se bat avec le policier qui
donc n'aurait pas été à l'origine de la
bagarre les deux sortent parce que ce
qui est très intrigant sur les images
c'est qu'un ado devant et empêche les
jeunes de filmer les policiers disent
les deux ont empêché le good d'entrer
dans le hall pour frapper notre collègue
les jeunes eux disent c'est un face à
face un contre un qui a été créée par
les policiers pour frapper le jeune quoi
qu'il arrive personne ne remet en doute
l'authenticité des images elles sont
vraies donc moi je trouve que à titre
conservatoire en attendant la fin de
l'enquêté il faut suspendre le policier
prendre bien sûr guillaume non mais choc
c'est insupportable ce tribunal des
réseaux sociaux cette affaire elle est
née sur les réseaux sociaux encore une
fois on juge une vidéo sorti de son
contexte en allées pavées et et du
cantal guirassy a pâti de la série
on voit pas très bien où sont les
policiers ou siens les prétendues
victimes et on veut juger et condamner
un policier peut être qu'ils n'avaient
pas d'autre choix que de se défendre
donc il faut laisser la police faire son
travail il aura peut-être une procédure
s'est pas encore décidée mais voilà
laisser les gens faire leur travail
arrêter de juger à la place de la
justice faut que je vous le dis c'est
qu'en fait ils sont donné rendez-vous
dans le hall d'immeuble pour faire un
face à face pour faire taper ça en fait
notre jeu c'est en fait pour l'action
d'ubs a bien dans le hall d'immeuble ils
sont humains d'accord devenir un pion
bah voila se taper ensemble du fond du
court ça quand même le temps de
comprendre c'est quand même assez voilà
c'est le sel était assez souvent pour
des besoins de nos amis policiers la
police et un décor administratif les
plus surveillées il ya 5 millions
d'interventions par an y en a juste 39
été radié définitivement l'année
dernière donc à 99,9 pour cent mais des
interventions qui se passe bien donc il
faut arrêter à chartres stigmatiser les
policiers et les jeunes sont forcément
des victimes attendons de voir il faut
qu'il ya une enquête jusqu'au bout et ne
pas suspendre a priori comme ça sur ces
images on sait rien mais si votre
version est vrai il doit d'autant plus
est suspendu cyril un policier qui va se
battre c'est pas du tout son rôle les
policiers c'est de la prévention ce
rendez compte de ce que vous êtes en
train de danser délirant franchement
viande
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]